I normally wouldn't ask a director to
expound on the title of his or her film
but because you've made this beautiful
meticulous exploration of a divorce and
called it marriage story
I love the decision and I'm curious what
was behind it well I always thought of
it as a love story and there's this this
is you know there's that sort of
philosophy of that or something I've
lost for I know has said and I don't
know who it is I should probably learn
it so I can answer the question better
but but the sort of notion that when
something stops working you take notice
of it in a way that you wouldn't
otherwise so your door doesn't open you
look at the door you you know otherwise
you just open it you don't think about
the door I mean we all deal with that
with cars you know you open up the hood
suddenly you're like well how does this
thing work you know when we all just
kind of go about our lives and I thought
well in a sense the could the the
divorce could could reflect on a
marriage the same way Alan what are your
recollections of your first interactions
with Noah when he heard when you were
talking about doing this film and what
your response was when you read the
script and particularly the character of
Bert's best well I would impressed me
the most was the beautiful writing of
the whole script which always interests
me more than the character I'm going to
play I wanna I want I don't want to be
in a movie I wouldn't want to go see I
don't know if everybody feels that way
but the thing that impressed me is what
you were just talking about that Noah
managed to make a movie about a divorce
that really is a love story and the
interesting thing is in in a marriage
you have to learn to collaborate you
have to learn to cooperate but when that
falls apart and you get a divorce you
actually have to cooperate better during
a divorce than you did during the
marriage which is ironic and Noah shows
that he shows how difficult it is and
how underneath it all they do love each
other and I think that's a that's an
amazing accomplishment that Noah has
achieved and I'm so glad to have been
able to be there with him while he did
it my first impression of Noah on the
set which you did ask me about I was
answering another question that was good
my first impression of Noah was how
relaxed he was and how open he was he
didn't he didn't he didn't give the
impression of being somebody who had the
whole movie in his head which every
director does and leads to sometimes
vagueness he was very available and I
really appreciated that and he was right
there with us all the time right while
we were doing figuring out the seams it
was not to do it this way or else you
know Julie when you saw the finished
product for the first time because I do
think that is one of the interesting
things about it is that as an audience
our Legion cesare shifting as well and
that's really fascinating also in
through the lens of your character well
I feel in the movie when the picture
when you watch it
you root for your feelings changes in
life when things happen you kind of
believe that story and then that story
changes and you go over there but that's
the perfection I think of Noah's
storytelling and that it's it's it's so
we were just talking a little minute ago
about the fact that the language when
you see it we were listening and we
didn't know that
was the movie we thought we were hearing
people speaking and it's it's really
hard to memorize because it's so honest
and how you talk and you think oh that's
easy but it's it's not easy because it's
not phony right David in many ways this
project is a combination of so many kind
of mini genres in one film you have
physical comedy you have domestic story
you have this kind of courtroom aspect
it's almost a musical and in some ways
how did that affect or heart but how did
that affect the way that you did your
job from a kind of production standpoint
from a producer really you and I
probably shouldn't say this but it was
relatively straightforward because Noah
is such a great communicator a great
communicator to his cast a great
communicator to his production sign a
Cosmo signer Cameron everybody he's he
has the film very much in his head and
yet he is open to the process of to
collaboration and he loves conversation
and discussion I mean when we were
talking about the script we would talk
for days about it and Noah loves to
serve stress test his ideas and explore
and go on the journey and yet he has
always such clarity and is very he's a
brilliant expressive communicator so you
know exactly what he wants so from my
point of view I suppose the greatest you
know one it was my first film with Noah
so getting to know him and his specific
ways of working but really my supposed
my biggest role was helping him create
the space for him to do the work that he
does he creates a very intimate space
for everyone in which everybody feels
safe to do the work you know you can see
that these actors and Adam and Scarlett
you know go to a very
they're very brave and they you know
they're Noah and they dare to fail which
i think is a remarkable thing to be a
part of is pushing the envelope that's a
high-wire act and it's sort of creating
the space for noah and everybody to do
the work that they do i do want to talk
about adam driver Scarlett Johansson
laura dern to be three performances I'm
just never gonna forget all three so
terrific yes Alan you have moments
scenes with Adam and Laura Julie you
have scenes with Adam and Scarlett what
are things that stick out when you the
two of you each think about those cast
members and working with them the main
thing that sticks out is their
generosity and true kindness and and fun
I mean trying to pick Adam up you know I
mean and sometimes he kind of because we
did it a few times he would kind of go
you know and try and be helpful but it
you created a space for us all to have
our freedom and joy and and trust and
playfulness and in all that stuff that
goes on so thank you for that Noah thank
you julie i most of my scenes were with
Adam and I was struck immediately by how
genuine he was both on camera and off
camera
he's he's really himself and he he knows
who he is as a person and that really
helps him be who he has to be when he
plays a character and he's able to find
in himself the spare parts for whatever
character is playing no matter how
different that is from who you see when
you meet him I saw him in the same week
that I saw this movie for the first time
I saw him play a completely different
character and burned this on Broadway I
mean they're polar opposites and you if
you only saw one of them you'd say
well of course he's just playing himself
because there was no artifice where he
just was the person and he is the person
when you talk to him when I'm very very
fond of and we got to be good friends
right away which is easy to do because
there's no there's no crap with him he's
really he's really honest we talked
about Adam I was just gonna say
something about Scarlett which I think I
mean the the monologue she delivers in
Nora's office which is I think was like
six seven pages and and and it was
always going to be one take so and we
shot on film so we'd always have to have
a new mag or else we'd roll out you know
we which would be a disaster at that
point you know and as a director you're
directing when you're jacking like a
really long take it is I mean you're
both like you know you're thinking about
the scene what the performance thing but
you're also at a certain point if it's
going well you really are just like
holding on like is this you know are we
gonna make it to the end you know
because there is no other way you know a
great take 3 that's 3/4 long is never
gonna we can't use it
so she was I mean what thing we talked
about in that in that for that scene was
also that I wanted her to kind of live
it as she said it you know that it
should almost feel like a theatrical
monologue on a sense of like you know
somebody in a play maybe walks down to
the you know to the footlights and sort
of tells the story and so when she's
she's you know when times are good she's
happy even times of you know that so it
was a lot for her to not only you know
the sort of journey of the the story
even as it is but also they required a
lot of her every take but I could give
her a note we would finish a take and
and and you know I could say something
you know maybe you could try you know
and and you know you're flipping through
the sides like here yeah and it could be
four minutes into it and and she could
she could take that in and then she
could she could do the whole thing and
it was like like almost sort of like I
felt like watching like a great athlete
do what they do best she could
make the adjustment and you know while
still doing everything you know in the
same mode of everything she's done it
before things we like things we want it
again and make these just precise
changes throughout while being
emotionally available you know true to
the moment I mean it was really it was
one of the earlier things we shot and I
really felt like you know I it was it
was a it was a kind of a great way to
get to know an actor you know Noah Allen
Julie David thank you so much
[Applause]